we're your oscar host i'm wanda sykes
i'm amy schumer and i'm
single okay
amy schumer wanda sykes and regina hall
bring the funny to the 2022 academy
awards and the whole thing was like a
big hollywood roast i want people that
haven't watched the oscars in years and
have a reason to tune in that's what i
think we got tonight we've been really
working i think will has done something
to really make people feel like oh we're
celebrating movies the trio kicked off
the show poking fun at their shared
hosting duties this year the academy
hired three women to host because it's
cheaper than hiring one man
and the zingers just kept rolling in you
know what's
what's in the in memoriam package this
year
the golden globes
the power of the dog oh
you know
i watched that movie three times and i'm
halfway through it
you know i was very disappointed that
space jam 2 did not get nominated in the
special effects category for that
hairline they gave lebron james last
month the comedians were announced as
the show's first hosts in three years it
was going to be an amazing night getting
to do this with regina and wanda they
are such heroes of mine they are comedy
royalty we've been having so much fun
the preparation has been the most fun i
said that like i've enjoyed every second
of getting ready with these ladies of
course last year producers scaled back
the oscars due to the coronavirus
pandemic we've been dealing with covet
for two years it's been really hard on
people yeah i mean just
look at timothy
oh god
i don't know it's not good yeah that's
67 year old jk simmons not 26 year old
timothy chalamet
the girls trip star announced that she
was single during the opening monologue
and later said she was asked to perform
emergency covet tests on some of the
most handsome eligible men in the room
i'm going to start with bradley cooper
timothy chalamet tyler perry simulator
and wait um javier bardem oh you're
still with penelope you know what
actually no no no
your your test is fine it says that
you're married i'm negative negative
can't blame a girl for shooting her shot
it's going to be a typical quick covet
test you'll come backstage take your
mask off if you have one and you're
closed and then i'm going to swap the
back of your mouth with my tongue and
we're just going to do some other freaky
stuff which i will record for
academy protocol really this isn't up to
me you know the truth is we're just
we're still in a pandemic but regina
didn't stop there the 51 year old
actress later introduced jason momoa and
josh brolin giving them what she dubbed
a covid patdown it's rough you know what
i mean i just gotta
get on down here make sure you okay
all right yeah let me get on in
there he's feeling good everybody
get on over here oh boy wow this is a
lot as for amy she took a hilarious dig
at leonardo dicaprio's dating history
leonardo dicaprio what can i even say
about him
he's done so much to fight climate
change and leave behind a cleaner
greener planet for his girlfriends
because he's older and they're younger
then there's wanda who strutted her
stuff on stage dressed as venus and
serena williams dad richard williams no
wonder richard williams was so stressed
his joke was squished of course later in
the night will smith won the award for
best actor for his performance as
richard williams in king richard after
he unexpectedly stormed the stage and
smacked chris rock who made a joke about
will's wife jada pinkett smith jaina i
love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it
all right
and after the slap heard around the
world
amy she addressed the elephant in the
room did i miss anything
[Applause]
there's like
there's like a different vibe in here
but before the big show the 40 year old
comedian told et she was just hoping her
two-year-old son jean would tune in to
help out with viewership does gene get
to stay up and watch mama tonight i
don't know i i hope he chooses me you
know mom and dad are out so he's got the
remote
oh he's he's on his own daniel tiger you
know gene come on
we need the ratings gene